[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK STUART DAY: Thanks very
much for the opportunity
to be here.
I am here to talk
about explaining
how our digital stuff works.
In particular, I'm here
in support of my new book,
"Bits to Bitcoin--
How Our Digital Stuff Works."
And in that context, there
are two different audiences
that I'm expecting that
I'm addressing today.
One of them is a
potential reader,
for whom the key question
is, is this my kind of book?
Am I interested?
And then there's also
a potential audience
of people who might
find themselves
in somewhat the position
that I found myself
in of having a certain
amount of technical expertise
and a modest amount
of inclination
to do something with it in terms
of sharing it with the world.
And you might be interested in
the question of what it takes
to get this kind of book done.
So let's go ahead and look
at the potential reader
side of that.
So that's the story of the book
in terms of what's in the book.
The book is described
in its blurb
as an accessible guide to
digital infrastructure.
And "accessible"
is a funny word.
In this context,
what it means is
that I ruled out a couple
of popular strategies
for how to explain the material.
One of the things
that you can do
if you want to explain computing
to people who don't necessarily
have a lot of
technical background
is you can kind of go through
the history of the field.
That's been done a lot.
I don't think it
really gets you very
close to the core
of what's happening,
for the same reason that when
you are, for example, choosing
to publish a
technical paper, you
don't talk about all the dead
ends that you went through
along the way.
So I also wanted to
focus on something that
didn't involve programming.
There's a lot of books
that teach you programming.
There are a lot of
books that assume
that you know programming
or that teach you
programming along the way.
But it seemed to
me as though one
of the things that
I could see is
that there were people for whom
programming was either a block,
or at least it was too much
work for them to take it on.
And so I wanted to
understand if it
was possible to
do something that
didn't depend on programming.
So my approach to
what's in the book--
I'm going to tell you
a little bit about how
the book is structured.
Then I'm going to show
you some selected topics.
There's a lot of
material in the book,
so I'm not going to come
anywhere close to covering
all that's in the book.
And even for the
things that I pick,
I'm not particularly trying
to explain any one subject
thoroughly.
I'm just trying to give you a
sense of the kind of approach
and the kinds of things
that are in the book.
But then I am going to come back
and look at something that I
would expect it would make
a difference if you had read
the book, in terms of
whether you understood
a particular comic
strip from XKCD.
OK.
The book structure--
it starts with the idea
of a single process,
just what a computation
is, what the limits are, what
the power of a single process
is.
Then it proceeds to
the question of what it
means when processes interact.
But for both single and
interacting processes,
the assumption is that nothing
in the world is going wrong.
The processes themselves
might have some problems,
but there's nothing about their
environment that's problematic.
In the third part--
unstoppable processes--
now you have the situation
that something can fail.
And so you want
to figure out how
to arrange your
resources so that you
can keep going in spite
of some kind of failure.
In the last part,
there are not just
these accidental or
natural kinds of failures,
but there are
deliberate failures.
There are attacks.
And the question
then becomes, what
does one do about
defending a process?
How does one continue
to work, even
in the presence of
deliberate attacks?
This is the list of chapters.
I'm not going to try
to walk through it.
But I just want to give you
a sense of what's in it.
The breaks between
these numbers correspond
to those different parts.
And I'm going to
use this so that you
get a sense of us
marching through the book
with these examples.
So I'm going to start by talking
about steps and the nature
of being digital.
So we can look at this
painting from the 19th century.
And we can say that
there was something
that was quite unusual and
radical about it at the time
that it was painted.
And that was that it was visibly
composed of discrete parts.
And this style of looking at
things as made up of parts
is kind of the
essence of what we
mean by saying that
things are digital,
that they have boundaries
that we can't recognize.
Now one of the questions that
people at this time would ask
is, why would you
do such a thing?
We can look at that
in a somewhat more
pragmatic engineering sense.
And I'll do that in a moment.
But the digital world,
for our purposes,
is composed of these
kinds of steps notions,
that the things
that are happening,
happen in discrete steps.
The things that the actions
are happening to are,
in some sense,
stepped or chunked.
And we can distinguish
between steps and ramps
as, in some sense, equivalent
ways of getting from point A
to point B, particularly
if, as in this example,
they have the same slope.
But your experience
of walking on these
is quite different in the
sense that if you just
take a small step to
the left or the right--
a small movement left
or right on the steps--
you may find yourself
making quite a sharp change
in the vertical
direction, whereas
a corresponding small shift to
the left or right on the ramp
is going to cause you to
only have a small shift
in your vertical direction.
This is, I'm sure,
obvious to all of you.
But it's not as
commonly recognized
that this is a way
of understanding what
analog versus digital is about.
Now these are not
implacably opposed worlds.
These are just different models.
We can take that idea of steps,
and we can make the steps
as close to the ramp as we like
by making the step smaller.
So that's a handy thing to know.
And then we can
ask the question,
as I suggested the
viewers of that art
might have asked, why are
we bothering to do this?
It seems sort of odd.
And one of the things
that's worth being aware of
is that you can take information
and you can transmit it
in the presence of noise
more effectively if you
are using a digital encoding.
So here we have a kind
of a wiggly analog signal
to which we're adding a
small amount of noise.
And that's just
happening because we're
trying to transmit
it through the world,
and the world is a noisy place.
And what we end up
with as a result
is this somewhat distorted
version of the original signal.
And the challenge that
we have in this setting
is that it's hard to tell
which parts of that result
came from the noise and
which parts were coming
from the original signal.
We have a somewhat
easier time if we
start with this chunky digital
signal in which the value is
bouncing back and forth between
this high and this low level,
because then when we add in
the same kind of low level
of wiggly noise, we wind
up with this, again,
somewhat distorted result. But
it's straightforward for us
to recover our signal
that we started with,
because we know that the
little wiggles in there
don't mean anything.
OK.
So that was a kind
of a quick excursion
into how we could talk about
what it means to be digital
and why you might even care.
Let's talk a little
bit about recursion.
And before I get
to that, I would
have had to say something
about names and names
as a basis of computation.
But I'm going to skip past that.
And we're instead
just going to start
with this notion of
acronyms as a kind
of a humorous way of bringing
up ideas involving recursion.
Now it's common
to have acronyms.
And people understand them
as substitutions between--
the short form of the
acronym is just the letters,
and then there's a longer form
that's a phrase or a name.
So for example, when we see
IBM, at least in the old days,
that was International
Business Machines.
FAA is the Federal
Aviation Administration.
NSA is the National
Security Agency.
You probably know lots
of acronyms like this.
So then we get to
this question of TLA.
TLA is an acronym that
means Three-Letter Acronym.
And so there's a
kind of a humor there
in that TLA is itself
a three-letter acronym.
Now let's consider a
slightly more evolved version
of that kind of
self-referential quality.
And let's consider
the acronym XINU.
XINU turns out to be an acronym
that means XINU Is Not Unix.
OK.
And that, again, is something
that we, as people, can look at
and can say that there
is something slightly
entertaining, something
that tickles our funny bone
about that.
But we also recognize that
there's a problem here,
in the sense that if
we just blindly went
on doing this expansion, we
don't get an improvement.
XINU is not Unix, is not
Unix, is not a better version.
Plus, its no closer to being
resolved than the first
one was.
So we've noticed that
there's both the potential
to have a name kind of
fold back on itself.
And we also have to be aware
of this potential infinite
expansion problem.
Let's shift gears a little bit
and talk about a Mother Goose
story, which you may or may not
remember from your childhood.
It starts with, "This is
the house that Jack built."
And it goes on to say, "This is
the malt that lay in the house
that Jack built. This is the
rat that ate the malt that
lay in the house
that Jack built.
This is the cat that killed the
rat that ate the malt that lay
in the house that Jack built.
Now this goes on for
a very long time.
It gets to be quite an
extensive set of things
that are happening to this malt
in the house that Jack built.
But the point, I think, is,
it's teaching children a pattern
about being able to keep
extending in terms of clauses.
Basically, the lesson
here is, you can always
stick one more
subordinate clause
into an English sentence,
following this pattern.
And you can, in fact--
if you are a computer
science type person--
you can start saying,
well, it's not enough
for me just to read
that Mother Goose rhyme.
How about if I write
some rules about it?
And the rules that
you wind up with
include this notion of
a compound phrase that
is defined in terms of itself.
And so you have this
phenomenon that something
that is quite familiar,
even to children,
turns out to have a mechanism
lurking inside it that's
this relatively interesting
computer science
concept of recursion.
And we also have the
observation here that
in addition to allowing you to
produce a phrase of arbitrary
size through this recursion,
that we don't have
to worry about the
infinite expansion
that we had with
the XINU example,
because this rule
involves two choices.
And in one of those choices,
it's not recursing anymore.
So we have a way out of
the trap, if you like.
OK.
So that was another example.
Let's talk about what
happens when things
fail in one way or another.
Here's a way that you might
think about disk drive
reliability.
I've read something
on the internet that
says that my disk drive has
a mean time before failure
of a million hours.
A million hours is
more than 100 years.
So I don't need to worry
about disk failure.
And the counterpart to this
is this poor person here,
who is drowning in water with
an average depth of six inches.
And so the cautionary
tale here, basically,
is that the mean time between
failure of a disk drive
is a statistical property.
And it's true of a very large
collection of disk drives.
But that doesn't mean
that it tells you reliably
how your particular disk
drive is going to behave.
So you need to do backups,
even though they're
a pain in the neck.
Something that I
wanted to include,
because I know there are
people in Cambridge who
are interested in CDMs or do
that as part of their job--
in the book, I talk a little
bit about constructing
a simple version of
how browsing works.
And then I revisit the topic,
in order to talk about some
of the things you need to do
to make these systems scale.
And one example is
that you can look
at the idea of having lots
of people all over the world
getting their content
from a single place.
And you can see that there
are two kinds of problems
with this.
First is that there
are a lot of arrows all
converging on this one site.
So that corresponds
to a lot of work
that site is going to have
to do and a lot of traffic
that's going to have to go
in and out of that site.
And you can also notice
that some of these lines
are quite long.
And that corresponds to
people having probably
poor performance, as it takes
a long time for their requests
and their response to
get back and forth.
And so we can immediately, just
in kind of an intuitive sense,
see the merit of some kind of
content distribution by saying,
I can take those
exact same clients,
and if I now have
three different sites
around the world that they
can get that content from,
there are fewer arrows going
into any one of those sites.
And the arrows collectively
got quite a bit shorter.
OK.
Let's talk a little bit
about some of the things
that go into the Bitcoin part.
So the flow of the
book is starting
from very simple
stuff, like, what
are bits, winding
up to more like,
how does this Bitcoin
thing work anyway?
And a piece of what
we need toward the end
is to understand something
about public key systems
and signatures.
So a public key system
involves this idea
that keys come in pairs--
private public pairs.
And that what that
allows you to do
is that if you're one
of these two defenders
that's trying to share
information with each other
without the attacker
getting at it,
this is a more complex system.
But your job as a
defender is much simpler
than it was if you were trying
to do this with secret keys.
It's simpler because
these private keys that
are shown up at the top, you can
keep them completely private.
You don't need to find some
cunning way of sharing them
with each other.
And meanwhile, these
public keys are things that
can be made completely public.
You don't need to worry
about keeping them secret.
So it's completely
fine in this world
that the attacker has
access to the public keys.
Why does it make a
difference that you
have these private
keys and public keys?
Well, one of the things that you
can do with them that's handy
and that turns out to
matter in moving the Bitcoin
ideas forward is to be
able to take some data
and combine it with
your private key
in order to produce something
that has been signed by you.
It doesn't hide the data.
It just makes it so that there
is an integrity check on it.
And that integrity
check is associated
with your private key.
OK.
And this complicated
machinery in the middle
is just sort of there to
establish that this is not
a trivial thing to
do, but we're also
not going to explain
it in any great detail.
So then what does
that allow you to do?
Now you can take
this signed data,
and you can combine it with
a corresponding public key.
Now there are some
tricky parts here
about how someone actually knows
which is the right public key.
That's a separate discussion.
But let's just, for
the moment, assume
that you know which public key
corresponds to the person who
allegedly signed this.
You can take the
signed data, you
can take the
corresponding public key,
and you can hand it to
another kind of machinery that
comes back with an answer
that says either, that's fine,
that corresponds to the
private key that was used,
or it says, no,
there's a problem.
If it says there's a problem,
you don't necessarily
know whether the problem is that
it was signed by someone else,
whether it just wasn't signed
in any kind of meaningful way
at all, or whether someone
has tampered with the data.
So it's worth being aware
that you don't necessarily
know what kind of
thing has gone wrong.
But it's powerful to know
that there is something
that you have as a check here.
OK.
So that was a small number of
topics and different points
of the book to kind of give
you a flavor of what kind
of material is being covered.
Now I want to show you an
example of the sort of thing
that just shows up in the
press, where, if you were not
a technical person, you
might well not understand
the point of the joke.
So here's an XKCD cartoon.
If you can't see the
URL, it's number 2030.
And the first couple of panels
are just basically setting up
the idea that other
engineering professions know
what they're doing.
So I'm not going to read them.
And the third one just
leads us into the question
of computerized voting.
The core of the discussion is
happening in the bottom two
panels, where the interviewer
is saying, "Wait, really?"
And the software
engineers are saying,
"Don't trust voting software,
and don't listen to anyone
who tells you it's safe."
"Why?"
"I don't know how to put
this, but our entire field
is quite bad at what we do.
And if you rely on us,
everyone will die."
And then the interviewer
goes on to say,
"They say they fixed it with
something called blockchain,"
which prompts the software
engineers to scream and say,
"Whatever they sold
you, don't touch it.
Bury it in the desert.
Wear gloves."
OK.
So one of the
things about this is
that you might not necessarily
understand why this
is mocking software engineers.
You might not understand why
a blockchain is causing people
to scream, why it just seems
like a stupendously bad idea
to get blockchain and
computerized voting
and software in general
all mixed up together.
Now, I have to tell you
that this cartoon is great,
because when I was
pitching this book,
one of the things that
people would ask me
is, what will people be
able to do after your book
that they couldn't do before?
And so they would
say things like,
will they know how to program?
And I'd have to say no.
Will they be able to
change their tire?
No.
Will they understand a
particular computer system
really well?
No.
They'll just sort of be better
at a lot of different things.
But you see, now I can point
to this cartoon, and I can say,
if they didn't understand this
cartoon before, I bet they
really do understand it now.
And here's my argument.
If we go through what
you need to understand
to get the jokes in the
cartoon, one part of it
is that software
is often flawed.
So I talk about that
a lot in chapter 6.
We also have to understand that
just because you know something
about how hardware systems
fail, that doesn't necessarily
mean you understand anything
about how software fails
or what to do about it.
So that's in chapter 17.
Security is intrinsically hard
is something that I talk about
in chapter 21.
Software trust is
especially hard.
I talk about that in chapter
22 in the context of what's
called the Ken Thompson hack.
Identity in
cryptographic systems
is not the same as
in ordinary life.
That's the piece
that we just went
through at the end of
the topics about the fact
that your private
key is basically how
you're identifying yourself.
And finally, we have the
fact that blockchain trust
is unproven.
Blockchain systems work for
some definition of "work."
But that's not quite
the same as saying
that people know whether
they can trust them
in all circumstances.
OK.
So that is a flavor of
what is in the book.
Now I would like to
turn to telling you
a little bit about what
it took to write the book
and to bring it to this point.
So this is the potential
writer story of the book piece.
And I want to go through
some common questions
that I get asked.
Why did I write a book?
I should be clear
that I have found
it fascinating to
meet people who
knew from their very early
years that they really
wanted to be a writer.
I am not one of those people.
But there was a part of
me that sort of thought
that, at some point
in my life, it would
be nice to publish a book.
And one of those things--
I think it would be overstating
it to call it a midlife crisis.
But a midlife swerve
or a midlife shift
took the form of saying, well,
you know, I'm turning 50,
and I'd be OK if I tried to
publish a book and failed,
but I would feel kind of
dumb if I never tried.
So if not now, when?
I had a further
motivation, because my wife
and I had the good fortune
to rear three smart
but non-technical children.
The smart part is nice.
The non-technical part is OK.
But it does mean that there
was sort of this quality
that I had spent all the
years that Chris was referring
to in which I was doing
distributed system stuff,
and I was basically
unable to explain
to my children kind of what
the point of it all was.
And I had already started
teaching at MIT as a transition
out of doing startup
kinds of things.
So the MIT part was
interesting, because there's
this class at MIT
called 6.033, which
is the undergraduate
systems class.
And it covers a combination
of operating systems,
network security, some
other things mixed in there.
It's a very demanding class.
I was just one small part
of the teaching staff.
It's a vast machine.
But I knew that I liked
teaching that material.
And I knew that I
wanted to find a way
to convey some of
what I thought was
fun and interesting about
that class to my children.
So was there an opening?
The textbook for
6.033 is a book that I
have a great deal of admiration
for by my colleagues, friends,
Kaashoek and Jerry Saltzer.
But it's quite long, and
it's quite technical.
And it was clear that
it wasn't the book
that they would want to read.
Meanwhile, there were lots
of books that were the sort
of "Computers for
Dummies"-style thing.
And what I found when I looked
at them was that they tended
to have a fair bit
of stuff about,
here's what's happening
inside a computer and not much
after that.
And I was interested
in sort of saying,
yes, now you know what's
inside a computer,
but now let's talk
about all the things
that computers can do
once you have them.
And as I mentioned
before, I didn't really
want to treat computer science
and programming as necessarily
near equivalence.
So my overall goals
were to cover things
that I thought were
interesting, or philosophically
entertaining, or
just entertaining
with no programming at all and
with my children as the target
audience and, as you'll
see shortly, my editors.
So how did I write the book?
So one part of writing
a book is that you
have to just keep at it.
There used to be a feature
in the "Financial Times"
where they would go talk to
authors about what their habits
and tendencies were.
And I noticed,
reading these items,
that they almost always
had some sort of routine
that they stuck to.
There was almost no commonality
to what their routines were.
But almost all of them said
that they had something
that they stuck to
very rigidly by way
of getting their writing done.
It was also helpful to
have manageable goals.
I was mostly focused on
getting this to be something
that my children liked.
Otherwise, it's really
easy to freak out
at how hard it could be.
And I had this
reviewing pipeline
from the most technical to
the least technical child.
So I would write a chapter,
and I would give it
to my youngest child, who was
16 when we started this process.
And when he got
to the point where
that was sort of
a working chapter,
then I would pass it
on to my middle child.
And this process would
repeat until it made it
past my oldest
child, at which time
I would be gathering up those
chapters that had made it
through the pipeline and
sending them in batches off
to a professional editor.
Because of the fact that
that editor was paid,
I had an incentive to
not do that too often.
There was an overhead
associated with the contracting.
OK.
How long did it take?
We have two different kinds of
time that are relevant here.
One of them is from when
I started writing anything
to when the manuscript was
handed over to the publisher.
And when I did the
math, that turned out
to be a little more
than four years.
That almost certainly
could have been less time.
I was doing a lot of other
things along the way.
But then after I turned
in the manuscript,
that was about another year.
And when you're an author
and you've written this book,
you sort of think, how hard can
it be to get this book done?
But I don't think
that it's actually
within your power to do very
much about that amount of time.
I did have an agent.
And so a lot of people
ask me the question,
how did I find an agent?
And initially, I didn't
think I would need an agent.
I didn't think I
wanted an agent.
I did due diligence of going to
my MIT colleagues and saying,
you published books recently.
What would be your advice to me
if I was trying to write a book
and publish it?
And they pretty
consistently said
that they would recommend
self-publishing.
And I thought, that's
interesting, good to know.
And I think that their
advice was correct.
But it required some
additional context
that I didn't
appreciate at the time.
I think that the
right advice is,
self-publishing
is the right thing
to do if you have
already published a book.
I think that-- it's
very surprising.
But it's hard to really know--
despite all the
resources out there,
it's hard to know what
it takes to produce
a book if you're doing it
all for the first time.
I think that I'd be much more--
I'm not particularly inclined
to self-publish anymore.
But I think it
would be much easier
for me to do so, having made
it through the process once.
So as I say, I thought I
was going to self-publish.
I just write and
write and write.
I wind up with a
substantial manuscript.
But I'm at the point where
I'm kind of tired of dealing
with this stuff.
And the things that
I thought I could
have done in terms of producing
and distributing this book
are seeming less appealing.
And so it seems like it would
be a good idea to get an agent
and see whether it's
possible to sell this book.
OK.
So one of the things that
you can do that's quite nice
is you can purchase
access to an agent.
The usual way that one
gets an agent is one
just sends letters to the
agents that the agents then
get in vast volumes and
somehow sift through.
But there are these
charitable settings
in which it's possible
to basically buy
some of an agent's time and
have them tell you either
that your book is
kind of appealing
or that it has no appeal
whatsoever and why.
And I thought this was probably
going to be worthwhile.
And I did get a positive
reaction in this context.
So we started working together.
But I did want to note, this
is not the conventional way
that you get an agent.
When I say that I got
a positive reaction,
this is the report that I got
back at our first meeting.
And there's kinds of nice
things in here about,
does the idea of the
book come through?
Yes.
Is the story
sufficiently described?
Yes.
Are the qualifications and
platform of the author clear?
Yes.
Is the font and
length appropriate?
Yes.
But then we get on to things--
oh, and there's this verdict,
would you have taken it?
Absolutely, right up my alley.
Ooh, that's very nice.
But then we have
these things like,
does first paragraph make
me want to keep reading?
No.
[LAUGHTER]
Does it feel like
this excerpt starts
in a logical and
compelling place?
No.
So there was still a
lot of work to do here.
I did want to put in a
word about Grub Street.
It's a writer cooperative
here in Boston.
There are writer cooperatives
like it in other cities.
They were the sponsor
of Manuscript Mart.
They also do lots of
classes and workshops.
They were very
helpful to me in terms
of getting this book
developed and finished.
And so I do want to
give them credit.
And I also want to
give credit to my wife
for sending me there.
Of course, it also got
me out of the house.
So that was part of it.
How did I find a publisher?
Well, MIT Press
published this book.
And I first had contact
with them in May 2014.
And I just sent them
an email saying,
I noticed that you seem to
be open to people sending you
books maybe or proposals.
And so we started
having conversations.
They've always been very nice,
even when they were saying no.
So we might ask
the question, given
that I was talking
to MIT Press before I
was talking to an agent,
did I really need an agent?
And probably, the
answer there is no.
If I just wanted to work with
MIT Press to develop the book,
I probably would have been
fine to just work directly
with them.
Lots of people do that.
Yes, I did need an
agent if my goal
was to explore all the
options for the book
and to be confident that
MIT Press was really
the right choice for
publishing the book, as opposed
to just kind of
being the default
one that was the first
one that I sent email to.
So writing and publishing--
this is the conventional rules
about what you do.
You write a proposal.
You get an agent.
You sell a book, at which point
you get half your advance.
You live off of your
advance to write the book.
You deliver the
book, at which point
you get the other
half of your advance,
and you pay off your debts.
The book is produced.
And then you market it.
You market the book.
OK.
That's not what I did.
I just wanted to note that this
is what you're supposed to do,
in case anyone is interested
in doing it that way.
What I did was to write
the book, get an agent,
write a proposal with
the agent, sell the book,
shorten the book,
deliver the book,
and then produce the book, and,
of course, market the book.
OK.
So I added a step here.
In addition to doing
things out of sequence,
I added "shorten book."
So why am I talking about that?
Well, this was the book
as I envisioned it when
I was in self-publishing mode.
This was an old title.
I don't know if anyone was
paying close enough attention,
but there was yet another
title on the agent's report.
The book has had a number
of different identities.
This book was 170,000 words.
And I'm not very
good at thinking
in terms of word count.
But it turns out that that's
certainly more than 600 pages.
And so that's a pretty
daunting kind of book
to think about a
beginner, a person who
wants to learn something
about this, dealing with.
So that wasn't going to work.
The book as published
is 100,000 words.
And that turns out to
translate into 368 pages.
And I think it's
probably about as big
as it could be and
still be appealing
for its intended audience.
So one of the
challenges is, I did
want it to be something
that was accessible.
I did want it to be a
modest kind of book.
I also wanted it to be an
illustrated book, which it is.
It's tough to do
all those things
and still keep the
page count down.
Was it worthwhile?
Yeah.
Overall, it's been great.
And I've sort of declared
myself a success in this space
ever since 2016, because
my original goal was just
to write a book
for the children.
And everything since then has
been a bonus and mostly fun.
I also came to realize
recently that it wasn't
a part of what I set out to do.
But I think that
along the way, I've
also had a chance to do some
things that I didn't get
to do in the startup
space in the sense
that I've never been a
founder, and I've never
been the key person shipping
some particular product.
But in this case, I am the
founder of this startup.
I am the person who
shipped this product.
And so that's a nice experience.
So that's the book.
That's the process.
I'd be very happy to
take your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: All the stuff
that got left out,
are you going to have a
director's cut or something?
Can I buy the extended Blu-ray?
MARK STUART DAY: One
way I think about that
is to say that I have the
material for a sequel,
or I have material
for smaller packages.
Some of the stuff that
wound up getting cut
probably would work well as
essential knowledge books.
So that's another possibility.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You have a website
listed on one of those pages.
Do you think about putting them
as blog posts on the website?
MARK STUART DAY: You mean the
things that I had to cut out?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MARK STUART DAY: Yes.
No, I think that that is
another likely destination.
I have a lot of
material, not just
because of what I cut out of
the book, but because I do still
have this writing routine.
And so pretty much
every day, I'm
writing whatever things
cross my fool mind that day.
And so some of the
time that's technical.
And some of the time it isn't.
But it does mean that
there is a lot of stuff
for blog posts and
possibly future books.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I just want to ask,
throughout the process
of writing the book and getting
the book published, which part
do you think is the hardest?
Like, what's your
biggest challenge?
And which part is the most
fun or the most enjoyable?
MARK STUART DAY: The writing
itself, especially when
the writing is going
well, is a lot of fun,
and especially when
you're convinced
that the fact that
you're writing well
and that it feels
good means that it's
going to turn effortlessly
into some fabulous book.
I think that the
parts that are hard--
cutting the stuff that you've
written so as to get down
to a word count
turns out to be hard,
if you're going to
get it to be coherent.
Doing the index
was simultaneously
fascinating and excruciating.
It's a fascinating
process because you're
working with the final
text of your book.
And what you're trying
to do is to collect
all of the conceptually
related things, wherever
they are scattered in the book.
And what you
discover is it's kind
of like an X-ray of your book.
You wind up realizing, oh, I
talked about this thing there,
and I also talked about it
here, but unfortunately, I
used different words
in the two places.
And so you learn a lot
about the way you write.
But it's unfortunately too late
for you to do anything about it
because you're doing it
on the final version.
And they're very clear
with you that you do not
get to rewrite your
book at this phase.
So that also-- my wife will
tell you that the period of time
when I was doing the
index, I would just
keep coming down and
saying, oh, I'm almost done,
I'm almost done.
I would do that for
weeks at a time.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: So you have two
interesting ranges in there
of how long it took
you to write the book.
But something you
didn't mention is
how long it took you to
acquire the knowledge
to write the book.
And that's from
the very beginning
up until the ending, how
much time you invested
during the writing to acquire
the knowledge that you
lacked when you started.
MARK STUART DAY: So
that's a good question.
One way we could
talk about this is
to say that the things
that I was writing about
are things that I
have effectively
learned over 30-plus years.
On the other hand,
there were also
some things where I
needed to go and learn
a specific piece of
technology just for the book.
Now, one example of this
was that I didn't really
understand some details
of how Wi-Fi works.
And I thought, that seems
like it would be a good thing
to include.
Now it turns out that that wound
up on the cutting room floor
when I had to cut
the book down again.
So it was a case where
I learned something
in a kind of a tactical mode.
And I produced an explanation
of it that I liked,
and then I had to
throw it away again.
But most of it, I
think, came down
to I had learned a
lot of this stuff
across the different
kinds of things I've done
in industry and in academia.
And really, the main
work of writing it,
other than the
construction of the text,
was to be thinking about
those things and saying,
I know how I would explain
those to a technical person,
but I have to think
about it differently.
I can't just fall back
on those kinds of things.
I'm going to have
to find some kind
of a metaphor, some kind of
an example, some kind of way
of tackling it.
And so I think that was a lot
of the intellectual process
of doing the book, was kind
of finding ways of saying,
I've got something
interesting technical to say,
but I can't use the ways that
people typically talk about it.
AUDIENCE: So what did you
leave out, other than Wi-Fi?
MARK STUART DAY:
Atomic transactions
I had to leave out pretty--
there's a mention
of them, but it's
sort of a hand-wave
that says, they
solve all kinds of problems.
I had to leave out
synchronizer failure--
the sort of boundary between the
analog and the digital world,
even though there are
some fascinating things
that happen there.
I have lots of slightly
dubious musings
about the nature of time.
And so those all
wound up on the floor.
I think that atomic transaction
was probably the biggest
piece that I had to take out.
AUDIENCE: So were you
worried that calling
the book "Bits to Bitcoin"
would lead people to focus more
on the Bitcoin than the bits?
MARK STUART DAY: Yes.
Well, that's still an
ongoing challenge for me,
in terms of the marketing.
On the one hand, it's nice
to have a title that attracts
attention, because it's timely.
On the other hand,
there is a little bit
of the possibility of either
disappointing the reader
because they expect it to be all
about Bitcoin or of misleading
the reader that they--
so yeah, the title is
sometimes a bit of a challenge.
But as you can see
from those other ones,
like "Unstoppable Time
Traveling Phantoms" or "Machines
Behind the Curtain,"
it's much improved.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank the speaker.
MARK STUART DAY: Great.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]